yo yo yo how's it going everybody this is uh techno geek here doing a little bit of a solo
episode today uh me and uh justin we woke up we were planning on recording today and i got a
message from justin about 30 minutes before and he was like yo dude i'm sick and i was like yo dude
me too so um i i volunteered as tribute um i am also feeling a little bit under the weather i
woke up this morning uh i don't know if it was pollen or jet lag or hopefully not covet or
something but um yeah it's uh it's definitely i'm feeling a little funky today and you can
probably hear it in my voice so i'm gonna try and do a little bit of a solo episode here i did want
to talk about a couple things um and uh yeah we'll uh we'll see if if this one uh ends up making it out
of the editing bay so um for those of you who don't know i've actually been uh dealing with some um
some hacking motivation uh stuff lately it's been pretty difficult for me to find you know the time
and the motivation and um sort of the energy uh just with day-to-day stuff um having a full-time job
and all that kind of stuff to to want to hack and and be able to find a target that i can really focus
in on and enjoy hacking um but i was able to sort of break that curse a little bit recently which was
awesome um i you know while i was on vacation i sort of got a little bit of a refresher it was nice to
um sort of clear my head and and be able to sit down and and focus again um and so i sort of just
picked a target that i was interested in um that i've been keeping an eye on for a while they happened
to be running a promotion um on hacker one as well so that was sort of just like good timing i was like
that looks interesting uh let me just take a little bit of a deep dive and i just started poking and um
you know things things went really well um i found a lot of really interesting gadgets
and um i just wanted to sort of talk about um you know how you can break that funk for yourself and i
think for me probably the biggest thing that i was able to do was to just sort of ignore um all of you
know what was going on in my head and really just return back to my roots um in terms of like hacking
uh methodology and procedure and um all that kind of stuff um you know for for me i think it was
difficult to um figure out where to want to spend my time and focus on again and i i just sort of was
like you know what let's keep it simple let's go to recon let's just find some assets let's see what
looks interesting and just poke poke poke until there's nothing to poke at anymore um and just take lots
of notes and find gadgets and start to piece stuff together or start to piece how different parts of
the application work um what sort of acronyms and definitions and architecture that they're using
um how they route between things what sort of protection mechanisms they might have in place
um and you know that was perfect for me you know i was sort of able to just um hone in a little bit
um i found a lot of really interesting things and um i got to a point where i felt a little bit stuck
and i reached out to justin and i was like hey man here's like some interesting functionality i had
and i just sort of brain dumped a lot of the things that i'd noticed a lot of the things that i had been
observing and a lot of the sort of potential you know 99 um almost there type of things that i had had
and immediately you know i was he was able to sort of bounce stuff back and be like hey here's an
xss here's a you know csrf like all these awesome things so i think a combination of having that deep
dive having the knowledge feeling like you um are sort of at at a really like far point in understanding
where the application is how it works and then having somebody that you can bounce stuff off of
whether that's um in the critical thinkers chat in the discord or um you know a mentor that you might
have or somebody who you like to hack and collab with um you know i think those types of resources
are really excellent for finishing your bug or getting new ideas and helping unblock yourself
because it's easy to sort of run through the same ideas over and over again in your head and be like
what about this i've already tried that what about this i've already tried that um and just you know
having having those resources available um of you know people other hackers other you know information
other exploit attack vectors um reading through those blog posts all that kind of stuff i think
it's really really important to just have those things in your back pocket so that when you do get
stuck or when you do find an almost bug that you can actually you know continue to push forward or or
have some sort of um you know path that you can take to try and take that all the way to a full bug
um yeah so i just wanted to you know share a little bit about that um you know you're not alone if uh
if you're feeling like uh you're stuck you can't find the motivation to hack um you know i think what
i'd recommend is just sort of do a brain reset and just you know ignore all of the you know whatever's
going on whether it's a lack of motivation or something um just the the first step to anything is
taking the step right you gotta lift your foot um and so i think uh you know it's always really
difficult to get yourself to do that um for me i think a good analogy was um you know like writing
a paper i really hate writing um and like writing is just not not my thing um but writing can be easy
once you get started um you know it tends to be that it's more just the whole concept of having to
write something or long form writing um can be very intimidating or very um you know you you see it
as like an elephant um but you got to eat it you know one bite at a time right um how do you run a
marathon one step at a time same thing so i think just sort of taking that first step and letting
yourself you know zone in um and ignore all of the you know what's the large picture here like what
about finding the rce or the you know the account takeover or whatever just you know take the first
step um just open burp open kaido open the application start proxying it just start poking
at requests create an account log in just explore um just start there and um you know your i think your
natural curiosity really helped take over and uh make it easier to continue and the more routes that you
discover the more things that you see within the application as potential bugs or potential attack
vectors um the more options you're going to have when you come back to it the next day and go all
right what do i look at next on this target um i think you know keeping those notes keeping those open
paths keeping those um those potential attack vectors and those potential bugs in the back of your
head are really good for motivating you motivating you to come back to the application and having
things to look at instead of just coming back to it the next day and having to basically start over
again um i think this is something that franz had talked about as well uh during our episode with him
which was that some of the best hacking is when he goes to sleep right before he feels like he's about
to exploit something so that the next day he's like itching to you know go and hack on that and finish that
bug um and and i think that's a really really positive um way to sort of encourage yourself and
motivate yourself to to keep hacking and keep coming back to it um so yeah i just wanted to share a
little bit about that um the other thing i want to talk about a little bit um ambassador world cup is
going on um looks like uh it's a pretty good competition so far i know a lot of stuff is still in
triage a lot of stuff is still uh sort of getting the severities figured out um it seems to be a pretty
tight race right now i'm not exactly sure who's winning yet so i don't want to um i don't want
to make a final call yet but um yeah i uh i personally haven't been able to do a ton of hacking
on that um as i was on vacation and i was just dealing with um some other stuff i had a wedding to
go to and all sorts of things so um but uh you know i've been looking at the american teams and uh
they're they're killing it it's uh it's awesome to see uh all my buddies finding really cool bugs on
these targets so um you know i'm hoping that uh we'll be able to push through into the next round
and i'll be able to contribute a little bit more but um yeah it's pretty awesome i know justin found
some cool stuff there and uh that that should be really really interesting um yeah so one other thing
i wanted to shout out was uh that on june 14th uh this friday we're going to be doing a another
master class specifically for the critical thinkers i'm going to be running this one it's going to be
specifically focused on mobile hacking and ssl pinning so i know a lot of people when they're
hacking on mobile apps or they're trying to you know find endpoints within a mobile app
one of the big things that you come across all the time is certificate pinning ssl pinning
and that can be a real big challenge especially when it's implemented in some custom or bespoke way
so this master class is really going to be focused on how to analyze that how to get around
those specific weird edge cases how to sort of trace where the pinning might be happening how to
track down within the app within the obfuscation how things are working how to bypass that um and
yeah it's going to be basically focused on everything as self-pending so if that's something you're
interested in if you're uh either trying to get into mobile hacking or you've been doing some mobile
hacking and really been struggling with the sell pinning or you've come across some weird sell pinning
cases uh make sure that you check out the discord um at ctbb.show discord and that'll take you right
to the discord and we'll uh we'll have that master class going on friday
all right dude franz we're rolling welcome to the podcast man thank you so much thanks for inviting
me of course and and so actually before we jump into this episode i've got to highlight what the
heck this thing is behind you um there's like a it looks like it's like a a framed poster of you with
a shell on google is that exactly what that is yeah it is it's it's from 2014 i think 2014 are you
kidding me holy no yeah yeah 14 yeah yeah were you born then dude i was i that's the year i graduated
high school actually yeah yeah no it's uh i think it was from an xxc if i recall it correctly wow dude
that's nuts so he's just got like etsy password on from a google box on the wall behind him that's
pretty freaking neat that's all right guys so as as we often do when we start off the critical thinking
podcast i'm gonna have to go into justin story time a little bit okay so justin story time is this
i i was at my the setting was this justin was a new a new bug bounty hunter and i had just weaseled my
way into my first live hacking event okay um and i had i i had i was very nervous i was the plus one of a
plus one and it was amazing to get to see all of these hackers that i um you know had respected for
so long uh but there was one guy in particular you may be able to guess who that i had not gone and
talked to you because i was just too nervous i was too nervous man i was like there's no way i can go
up and talk to franz or isn't and i was talking to my wife mariah and i was like listen franz is like
a legend like i can't i can't go up and talk to him and she's like justin you're at this live hacking
that you have to go up and talk to him and at that event you had found a crazy bug um with with uh
you know an s3 bucket you know pulling stuff in and stuff like that um and so i went up and talked
to you and you were so kind to explain the whole bug to me and just chat and that was my my first you
know fanboy moment where i was like wait a second franz is a real human what's up with that so wow
yeah oh that's amazing yeah that's an awesome story you know normally they say don't meet your
heroes but i must say franz you did not disappoint so that's awesome that's awesome yeah so there's
your little there's your little flattering intro um for those of you that don't know franz um franz is
a legend a a hacker a uh a bug bounty og um and dude i'm looking at this this this plan that we have
for this episode and it's so long i'm not even sure we're going to be able to get through all this
because there's just so much good content that you've put out um so thank you for that but before
we get into all that let's go ahead and talk about how you got into bug bounty in the first place because
you you got in when it was really early on the scene and give us a little career walk through that
brought you to the point where you could do bug bounty sure i think i mean initially everything
started off as hiring two young people uh to my company as developers and these two young guys uh
matthias karlsson and frederick anruth uh they were lurking always inside in a corner in the office
doing stuff together always and and you you didn't figure like you couldn't really understand what they
were doing but but when you started talking with them you realized like they were probably like art
spoofing the whole office oh my gosh laughing laughing okay so i'm gonna pause you really
quickly there so you you were you at this point you were already an entrepreneur so you started yeah
yeah you had already started your company yeah yeah so i can start when when i was born no no no so
yeah exactly no so i i started as a developer like super early on and then uh i i built the company
together with uh with a business partner of mine and we hired frederick and and matthias and at that
time i i wasn't into hacking i i knew that like sanitize your inputs that was that was basically the
sure sure the the the idea that i that i knew was was something in regards to security uh but this was
very timed also because like this was 2000 and i think 10 or 11 or something and and i i got curious on
what they were doing and at some point they told us that they were planning on building like a company
security like a security company automating security issues so we were pretty interested in that and we
started talking more deep around like what would you do what like what is the product and we kind of
realized uh early on that we could do this together especially because we saw a need for it in terms
of what we were building we were building like e-commerce websites and and cms websites and so
so we we then created detectify and uh and at that point just when we got started the bug bounty scene
uh basically was initiated so it started with like mozilla and i think it was paypal and google and i
think facebook was early on as well and then you had you had like like russian things as well and and some
uh what was it there was something else also that was like super early on i think ebay was early on as
well like there was a few of those that that started uh and and you you basically had like a a way to do
like research on a huge amount of surface like you could test a bunch of things on on this attack surface
and so that was very helpful in like getting to understand what they were looking for but because now you
you didn't have to like hide or simulate fake things you could literally like focus on on looking for
real bugs so that got me curious on like what should i start with and i think they they basically showed
me a bunch of xss things and and that that's where i like started off and uh and played like xss was my
you know where i was born sure and then and then it grew from there and so i think that was i think it
was very helpful for me to have people next to me that i could ask and also to to you know whenever
i didn't know anything i could just ask them and and then i could play myself and then i could come
back and like get that feedback this is so awesome because you you you you were in a position of you
know owning this company or whatever and you hire matthias i didn't know that that was actually how you
you met matthias in the first place and then you're willing you know you're willing and engaged at a
level where you know you can say like hey what are you doing and then you start this company with
them and it just shows this really you know learner mentality and matthias is like absolutely you know
matthias is young at this point right yeah yeah i think they were they were drop-offs from from the
university i think it was like they were like 18 or 19. no way even that wow so they were really young
yeah yeah absolutely and and they they came basically in and and like they were they were okay
developers but they were much better when it comes to like security and and security related things
that's when when they were like shining in terms of skills yeah so we felt that like it's much better
for you to like focus on those things than you know making an integration with an invoice uh provider
like please stop writing code yeah yeah no not really like write other code that is like much more fun
to know that's that's wrong i i i've been meaning to get matthias on the pod as well so i think i'm
going to send him a message right after this episode because i'd love to hear his origin story
as well and his side of this situation where he's like so there's this guy and he hired me onto this
company and then he's like why are you arp spoofing the whole office you know i love that he's like he
probably has a totally different story he's like no i wasn't hired i just came into this company i just
showed up one day i didn't get paid yeah right right exactly okay so that's really interesting to to
hear that that um that like shift so you were basically just doing entirely like software
development when you learned about like the security side of it what sort of piqued your
interest to like make that pivot that like really drew you towards security because i imagine like if
you're doing a lot of software development stuff you probably could have just kept doing that and not
sure made made a switch into security so what what was that like draw i think i i think so i've been
like i i was building you know systems like you you say you're building a system but like what is a
system in in in reality but i was always like as a developer i always tried to like oh i can reuse
this i need to build this like modular and and all these things so i was always curious on how others
were doing it and this was like i've realized this probably now after like 14 years but i i kind of
know that like through the whole time but like i'm super curious on how other people thought about
problems and issues and i've i've always like i've almost made it a a challenge to myself to write
like pseudocode of how something is implemented so i can make a black box a white box right right just
because that's the way i understand how they thought about things and also that's how you find
that specific little if statement that they forgot about sure and i think i think that was that was the
point where i realized that i could do this on other companies and nobody will like get me into trouble
and i can just you know start poking at them and see what's what what will happen and i think that was
that was something that i'd like i can do this and also get paid like this was something i was poking at
before you know just figuring out how stuff worked um and now i could do it help other companies and
also you know get paid for it yeah so i think that was that was the trigger to like okay i can actually
gain knowledge by doing this and also i have like a side effect of i can actually you know make make money
for it yeah absolutely and and i think go ahead no no and i think what what happened in the beginning
also when we started with the bug bounty was like those those money came in to our company so we could
fund you know this company like start these other companies so it kind of it it was like a very like a
beautiful yeah environment of like we get to poke on other companies and that creates other companies and
it was like it was a very nice you know circling effect of of of hunting for bugs and and you see
this a lot with with bug bounty origin companies right like in the beginning when you're trying to
like make ends meet and stuff like that you can even use bug bounty to fund your own company right
as you come into the company so i think that provides a really nice launching place for um you know
bug bounty hunters to uh become entrepreneurs in that context for sure there are many that that has
like popped up yeah yeah and i've got i've i actually was just speaking to another one this morning who
will have on the pod so there's definitely some that's one of the things i'm really interested in
is bug bounty plus entrepreneurship so we'll definitely cover more of that later and i've actually got a
section on this doc if we get through all of it to pick your brain a little bit more about that
um but i think you said a really interesting thing relating to how you think about hacking which was
that you try to write pseudocode so that you can kind of understand how the developers you know
what would have would have written this code and turn it you know from a black box into a white box
um and i've i kind of saw this when we were collaborating at the last life hacking event we were
at um and and you can get like small indicators and that like this indicator confirms that they've done
something like this because if this doesn't happen then and and it turns almost into a like a game
where you can like i'm gonna guess what happens if i do this i'm gonna get an error and then like yes
i'm getting an error okay then i know that they've done this and that yeah exactly like yeah that that's
that's and i think that's probably one of the things that makes you such a good uh exploit exploiter
exploitationist yeah you know like i don't know i don't know the actual word but um you know someone
who's really able to take an issue and just poke poke poke poke poke poke poke until you turn it into a crazy
vulnerability um so that's that's definitely a cool tip for anybody who has that sort of
developer-like brain to kind of you know really be intentional about theorizing because i think to
some degree we're all doing this a little bit when we're hacking but i think if you take that extra
step and really start thinking in the forefront of your brain hey how did they write this how is this
how can i confirm this you know what little errors might tell me whether it's this or that um you can
flesh it out a lot more and it's the same thing like when when you've done it with one place and
they have done you know a similar thing somewhere else yeah then you can like start comparing them
and like okay but it behaves differently there like you can so as soon as you've done that for like one
code block yeah you can see other implementations in the same company if they've done like you've done
a mistake on one like that that happens a lot like there's one single thing that that makes everything
break yeah sorry joel yeah no no absolutely i mean there's almost like two different buckets of of
this type of stuff when you're doing testing where um like the cat just
he's part of the show too um yeah but there's almost like two buckets where like
uh you you can there's like lots of like almost totally like out of left field type of stuff where
your test you'll be like maybe they did this maybe they did that like you never know maybe maybe they
made this weird mistake like i saw this somewhere else and then there's the very like logical approach
where you think about it so sort of basically as if you're one of the developers or you're coming
from the developer's perspective which is you know you know some of the technologies that they're using
you know some of the common mistakes that happen within those languages and those technologies
and so you can sort of piece things together you can try things that are a little more targeted
towards like say you're testing you know a java application you're going to test stuff that's
similar to spring or you know you're going to be testing for like java specific things instead of
like absolutely ruby issues or javascript issues yeah and that type of testing like it's not to say
that if you test a ruby issue on a java stack that like maybe there's something further down the line
that might pop and you know but oftentimes having that context as like a developer is really really
useful because you absolutely have that like that background of like i would say this is something
weird that they might have done yeah and i would say one one of the things you're mentioning there
is like like i don't know why i think people are talking about it in a different context but like
typing is like one of the most one of the best things and one of the worst things in combination
that you can use like that's one of our biggest tools that we have is is when like for example when
you have php you don't have typing so that's where what you have there is like then you can start
figuring out where they screwed up and thought it wasn't in but it's a string and and in other languages
it's like just because you have the typing errors you can start fussing you know variables that didn't
exist because you're getting a typing error and so like when you think about it like that's that's
one of my best clues that there's you know that i can hunt for things it's like typing issues
or typing errors basically yeah absolutely and i feel like that's a really good transition into one
of the tools that you wrote i don't know when was this like 2017 or something um just like this s3
decloaking tool oh yeah this disclosure tool yeah do you want to like talk about that a little bit
because there's you did a whole blog post and stuff but i feel like yeah i've got you yeah the blog
post is is so what happened with that blog post was like i i had fun bugs that i wanted to explain
but then i realized okay i need to take one step back like do people know what this is and like do
people know why this bug happens and do people know what s3 is and then like do people know what
the internet is and like that that the blog post just grew up no did i lose you yeah yeah i saw that yeah so
it's looking right now it says you're one percent uploaded do you have any one percent uploading do
do you have so normally it goes from one to zero always yeah so so do you have a way to um like
make your internet stronger like are you etherneted in right now or are you i can i can try i wonder what
i have for uh what i have on my phone instead because it's it's weird because it says oh wow maybe
could i've been the stupid person in the room what did you what did you do i don't want to say
i don't know what i'm saying okay he's got proxy on right now
i turn it off
i think it works at nine percent uploaded that was definitely it
all right so all right it goes to s3
it goes to s3
all right wait wait uh i need to check my my oh yeah sorry it was my my mistake yeah so
yeah everything went through burp man dude that's hilarious okay so so we we've been dealing with
some issues with franz cutting in and out for this past like 20 minutes and you know what it was he
left freaking burt proxy on so classic hacker mistake here um so i'm not sure really sure where where it
cut out but we'll we'll bring it back around in peace burp state yeah yeah dude your burp file just blew
up um but yeah okay so you know you talked a little bit about about you know the testing methodology
where you're you're thinking about you know the code structures you're thinking about things like
variable typing first and i will say you know uh when you said typing for the first time i was like
yeah man you know everybody types when they're hacking oh okay what the heck are you talking about
typing is one of our greatest tools about typing as well that's really funny but um so i guess i
wanted to dive a little bit into that so we've seen the side already we've or at least we talked a
little bit about the side of like uh exploitationist fronds you know once you see a weird issue you
you poke at it you model out the code you know you're thinking about how the developer would have
implemented it and you're thinking about how you can validate those assumptions by triggering different
edge cases throughout throughout the code base um i i'm curious about fleshing a little bit more out
about your your hacker methodology because one of the things we've seen in in the past with hackers
that have come on here is that you you have a couple extremes right you have people that are you know
um that go really hard on the recon stuff and you've got people that that go really hard on the um you
know on the on the manual hacking stuff right yeah um and so uh there's definitely different types of
hackers but i've seen you do do both and i think when you've got someone that they can do both it
it creates a crazy result so but i did want to ask you you know if you identify a little bit more as
as one or the other do you identify a little bit more as a manual hacker or as a a wide hacker you know
focusing on recon to find weird stuff or do you see yourself as a mix of the two so i i began mostly
so i think it's it's a matter of difference in terms of like where i'm at yeah so i would say i
started off of course manual and because everybody does that you need to figure out what to do before
you can automate it sure i then went into like full full-on automation like i wanted but but there was
always like i always had the argument on like you can't automate if you don't know what you're looking
for yeah and if your whole idea is to find something you don't know of you can't really
automate it all so i was never i was never a full-on automationist if that's a word yeah i was more on
like i automated a bunch of things i knew what i was looking for but then i always kept this thing
where i'm like i'm gonna save it all and and i'm gonna look through it and i'm gonna see the oddities
myself sure because i don't know what what i will find the things will happen much faster than my
knowledge about what what it is basically um but then then it came i think it happened i took a break
from bug hunting or like break it was probably like one and a half year or something like probably during
covid mostly yeah where where i didn't want to do any live hacking events i wasn't really looking for
bugs in in any way during almost two years yeah um and when i came back i kind of realized that
similar to i think what other bug hunters that like want to start off realize is that there's so many
people that are doing automation that is like ridiculous like seriously like absolutely they do things
so fast i i tend to i spoke a lot about my automation back in the day and i told them like
yeah i'm doing like every eight hours i'm looking and they're like every eight hours i'm doing it every
20 minutes every eight seconds you know like yeah exactly and i'm like they're like you're missing out
on so many things i'm like i can imagine yeah and i'm like do i want to invest the time to like speed up
my my automation just for those bugs and i it came to the conclusion that like no i don't
i i rather i rather spend you know manual time trying to figure out really cool bugs than trying
to like like reach to the point where i'm like at level with other automationists yeah no automation
is i love that word yeah it's an awesome i think we're gonna coin that term arts and automation is
you know yeah i i and it's actually funny you know i actually had that exact same path you know
except i sort of skipped to the part where i was doing manual hacking in the beginning like
because there were so many resources by the time i started you know when i started i guess in 2017
2018 you know you had already put out talks you know people were putting out talks on how to do stuff
so i had a pretty decent flow of like bug bounty write-ups yeah and stuff like that to read and then
i leveraged into automation but then i came to the same conclusion you did which is like well maybe a
little bit different of one but essentially you know in order to compete at this at this game at the top
level you have to be constantly refactoring your code yeah and it's a grind right and it's going to
make it more of a pro you're going to become more of a programmer than you are of a hacker because um
you know you're constantly having to refactor code um and and so i i also sort of leveraged a little bit
more or switched over into into manual hacking a little bit more and it's been fun to see see the
results of that as well yeah um i i think like and when i also when i think about it like when i
mentally think about like what do i wanna like end up with or like what do i want to succeed with
it's not that i like oh i'm i dream of finding a unclaimed f3 bucket like that's that's really not
the bug that i'm i'm like i will go home exactly and be happy about the the bug i will go home be
happy about is the one where i'm like i did this thing over there and that gave me a little piece of
the puzzle and then i went over there and did that and now i i can access the server like with an rc
like those are the kind of bugs that i'm like oh i'm gonna feel so proud and it's like it's gonna
it's gonna hold up for you know more than a week probably sometimes a year that bug has the value of
like and i i will not find that by writing automation and finding an unseen bucket or
uh you know environment variable file laying somewhere that might be helpful into doing other
things but you know it's the the fun the fun things happen when when i go deep so i i absolutely shifted
over to like go deep deep full on you know go you know so deep that that people are like but move on
man like stop looking at that thing yeah but but i'm like keep digging and like something sometimes
there's something falling out from it and like you realize you know and i have i have all these
examples of you know running on a private program but but still you know grinding it for for months
and and even collaborating uh with with matthias in this case and like we couldn't figure figure one
thing out and it was like how does this work and why is it happening and like he was he was at a
concert i think it was i don't know if it was like iron maiden or something but he was at a concert
and i was writing him messages because we often chat without the other one responding like that's
how we communicate like a synchrony is very very much asynchronous and i was writing to him like okay
but this worked like i don't know and and like it took probably two or three hours and that chat
message history is like is a beauty of itself because it's like this happened i think this oh my god
like it ended up in like being like a total disaster and and it was like you know ring the
bells and it was like one of the most beautiful bugs i've ever seen and it was just just that grind
of like we've been having this for for months knowing that there's something there but we couldn't figure
it out and it came to that conclusion it's like it's so beautiful and it's and it's like that's the kind
of bugs i want to come like like continue to you know bring home or you know talk about in in the
future yeah absolutely i i feel like for a long time there was this like there was a lot of manual
hacking that went on and then there was like a few years kind of like right before covid like around
covid and then like during covid where like a lot of people realize that there's so much scope and
there's so much stuff out there yeah that you can make a lot of money just by doing automation and
like automation isn't a particularly difficult thing there's a lot of tools out there stuff like nuclei
and all these like frameworks and things that exist that let you kind of just like duct tape and bootstrap
stuff together and just like build these little pipelines that do like a lot of like really efficient
work and so a lot of people just really like dove head first into that and just started like
scanning for stuff finding subdomain takeovers finding bucket takeovers finding like
you know cves that you could just like automate into you know easily reproducible reports and bugs
and like yeah that's a it's almost like a separate bug bounty space absolutely because it's like yeah
you're basically at this point you're not really like fighting over like complexity of bugs or like how
this app like interacts with other parts of the app or how that service or this website might like you
know be leveraged by another part of the application or another part of the company it's more just like
how fast is your tooling and like how good can can you beat the other person is your internet better
is you know are you is you're scanning faster are you looking at the right things yes and i agree i
really love this manual hacking type of mentality like me and justin have discussed this a little bit
because as a full-time hunter i think it's a lot easier to either fall more towards automation or at
least towards like less complex findings because you need that cash flow you need to be having reports
going in all the time sure but i also like i love not feeling obligated to have reports in because
that gives you that opportunity to do what you're talking about like go deep with the application
get intimate as we like to say really like learn the ins and outs of this application become like
almost a developer essentially at the company where you understand more about how stuff is going
on in the back end than even somebody who works at the company does because that really gives you
all those insights into where stuff is like faltering or where there might be weird mechanisms or the
systemic patterns like you talked about where you know you realize oh this is like a common mistake
or pitfall that they've made maybe they made this here and here and here and so on and i just love that
that mentality of just like you know ignore the the sort of the the flash and the glamour and stuff
but it's just like bug after bug after bug and find that really really cool deep and i agree i think
i think one of the so i went full bug hunting mode last i would say in beginning of september october kind
of and and the decision i made was happening during that summer and i because i had those kind of you
know anxious uh things also like will i be able to like pay my own salary or like how how can i figure
out the economics around doing this full time uh and at that point i i i had i had luck because i i
done like i did a few zoom on uh like bugs on zoom and they paid me out that summer and they paid really
well for those bugs so at that point i'm like okay this is my buffer so i have a buffer now of like if i
would take like my normal salary i would i would like last these amount of months okay so these months i can
i can figure out if i should you know go automation or continue doing because those bugs i found was
like no automation was just like trying to figure out how everything works uh and i used that time to
like figure out first like where should i hunt like what program takes care of me what program you know
treats my bug bugs in a way that i feel appreciated or like they value my my time and then also like
economical wise like where should i spend my time to like align the return on investment in a way that
makes me not stressed you know going forward um and when i figure those things out like where to look
i still trying to figure out like what programs i should focus on but when i figured out some of it
at least that helped me a lot in into like deciding that going deep was actually you know monetary wise
uh a good decision for me to like don't be afraid that that i won't be able to pay myself a salary but
yeah yeah i i think you definitely see if you look at the numbers i think you'll see a higher um return
on investment of time right and a highly a higher hourly rate if you do deep bugs but the thing with with
automation is you get to have this and i experienced this when i was in automation game
if you take time off you still get bugs right yeah which is just huge for like relief right you know
like because i don't know what it is for me but like even if i have a ton of money sitting in the bank
if i see that trending downward while i'm taking a break or if i if i know like hey i'm not finding bugs
right now that just bothers me you know yeah and i can imagine it's kind of like a it's it's definitely
a psychological problem um you know for sure but because i think you should be able to rest in both
states whether you just popped you know 100k and bugs and now you take you know a couple weeks off and
you've got that 100k sitting in the bank and you're like all right i'm fine or whether you've got you know
20k in the bank and you're you see it going up and up and up and up with the bugs you know those are the
same the same things uh but you know psychologically it's it's it's very different i think um we also
have a whole episode about like picking the right program and i think you you covered this a little
bit but it's really important especially like when you're doing full-time hacking to have the right
program yeah you mentioned like once you find like a program who really respects you as a researcher
and your reports and like handles the things that you're submitting and takes it very seriously and is
like you know responsive and all these types of things like it makes a really big difference to
like i i i almost want to say that it increases the quality of the bugs that you find later on
because like you have this relationship with the company where you want to show them like hey i found
this really cool thing on on your app like let me show you like let me take it one step further like
let me you know i i bet you thought that last bug was cool but how about this yeah yeah exactly it's
almost like a challenge yeah and um if you find a company that that not only treats you right but pays
correctly like if you have a program say they pay like 5k crits and their mediums are like 750
a couple media like you know you're like five mediums you're almost there right yeah and so
it's like if you have automation that's finding a bunch of mediums versus it takes you a week or two
to find like a really bad crit but it's only gonna get paid 5k then that trade-off isn't always worth
it but if you have a program that's paying like 30k crits yeah and maybe their mediums are like
one or 2k well that makes a big difference and then your time is really really worth like
spending that time finding that critical and not spending it doing automation or like trying to
find a subdomain take yeah let let me jump in here and say you know i think we've made it clear enough
but i want to clarify we have tremendous respect for people on both sides of the game um sure you know
and and you know uh there's definitely so many challenges of recon and so many challenges of deep
diving stuff um so but hopefully this has given a little bit of insight into the the thought because
i think all of us joel more so than me but you know have leveraged a little bit more into the whole
finding very high impact bugs um you know with the majority of your time and and franz as well um and so
okay but we've already been talking for a while and i'm two bullet points down on my little list so let me
let me let me let me let me just start the episode he's like we got so much to cover for like 30 minutes
we've talked about two topics yeah i'm like super stressed over here let me get back to my list okay
um no okay so i i do want to ask a couple things and we'll keep these pretty pretty rapid fire i think
um so you know you said you you identify more now as as sort of a deep deep dive hacker which i think is
is on point um and so and i think i know the answer to this because you already alluded to it but
i'm wondering how much time it takes you to how much time you normally spend on a program on average
and how much time it normally takes you to find some bugs that you're proud of i would say so i
haven't jumped between programs that much since i started with this methodology but the one the times
i've done it during these two years i would say i i think and this is like where the imposter syndrome
also hits hard uh every time it's because whenever you change your switch program you basically have
these you know sometimes for me it can take up to like three days until i actually find you know
something that i i think is relevant or valuable yeah and so so and i i train myself to not like i you
know you feel oh yeah yeah like you hate yourself yeah and you think you're a fraud and you know all these
kind of you know thoughts come up but at some point you're like okay but no i i know this time is
there you need to invest the time and you know because and and it's interesting also because if
you compare the first day you see a bunch of you know variable names or like parameter names and like
what what is this what is this i i have no idea i just want to find a bug like ignore what they are
like and the third day you're like oh i know exactly what that parameter does and like what it does okay
so that's why so you need to like spend those three days to like get that you know mindset of like
like the taxonomy for example taxonomy is a huge huge thing like what do they call you know this kind
of object and yeah like as soon as so i i tend to like write down taxonomy for myself just to like
understand what is referencing what then at some point like that's also a really good receipt for okay
they're calling it a little bit different here like they use they used you know a pascal case over
here but there's snake case over there and like those kind of things is like indicators that there
are multiple people doing doing things here and they've named it differently like that's an indicator
and and those things takes probably like three days to realize that this is an outlier for example so
let me let me just highlight that just for the listeners okay do you guys hear the level of depth
that he's he's describing here he's describing the the case the case of parameters and he and and he's
he's taking notes on the the verbiage the the wording the taxonomy of the various parameters and and
endpoints and and this is the kind of stuff that you would think is getting too minute too too detailed
but it's totally not no no because every single every single thing every time you go that deep
you get a further and further a little bit little just a little little tiny bit closer to understanding
what it's what it's looking like for this whole application and and that that little step little
step by step there makes all the difference in the world when it comes to sort of black box texting
when at the end of the day you're totally you know you're totally looking at a black box you know you
have no idea what you're working on absolutely so um and there's some there's some good tricks there
there's a number i'm with you man like i yeah yeah i mean there's some good tricks you can do like
sometimes i just take the full scope and i i search for the host in burp search and then i copy
everything into an xml file and i have like an unpack unpack burp state or unpack burp list
and then i check the body of the request and then i take all the words i have and then i sort them and
make them unique and then i can see like okay there's like intent id but there's like intent underscore
id and then suddenly i can like go that way to like find oddities in in parameters as well yeah and
and those are those you know if you've got intent id snake case in intent underscore id you know those
are parameters that were clearly implemented by different developers right or different you know
life cycle flows right right there right and so um you know there's definitely a good chance that if
every single intent uppercase i id is secure that sometimes the intent underscore id will not be secure
right so having that that sort of frameworks in place can really help you um understand you know
that the app from a holistic perspective and just take you know also i just want to shout out that that
ability to take notes to to or not necessarily take notes but like to process the data that you've got there
you know exporting to burp taking the time to write the xml unpack script which is something i've never
done by the way because it's just such a pain i can share it i can share it it's awesome yeah that would
be great um yeah it is something that will differentiate you from other hackers right you don't even have to
know that it's the right thing to do you know so many people are like man should i spend my time doing
this it doesn't matter it's going to make you unique as a hacker let's say you do that nothing comes of it
you still saw more of the application than someone else who who hasn't done that right you you looked
at those parameters a little bit differently you know because you unpacked everything so yeah it's
the things that make us unique hackers like that that that really allow different people to find
different crazy bugs yeah yeah i also think that there's like a whole aspect like the whole becoming
almost like a developer within that environment where if you learn the terminology and you learn what
things mean so many developers use abbreviations and stuff to like represent things like they they
might uh you know take something that represents some system right and they might abbreviate it as
three characters and just start using that as an acronym like throughout their application throughout
different like you know endpoints or parameter calls and stuff a lot of times i'll look at something
like that and i'll say like what like what is what is this like what is this these three letters what is
this supposed to mean like what what does this represent to the developer and once you
identify at a lower level like what does this actually mean what are they referencing when
they're saying you know these three characters or whatever you can really start to unpack hidden
functionality and this type of stuff that may even exist that you know you'll start to stretch to
different ideas like oh maybe if they're calling uh an endpoint with a different three-letter acronym
maybe i can toss my three-letter acronym that i know what this means maybe i can hit a different service
or something right and i think like getting to that level of just being like what does that mean
or what is this parameter doing or what does this represent can let you get that much deeper
understanding and be able to dive deeper within the application so much easier yeah yeah 100 um so
let me let me ask this then um i i have seen i'm thinking specifically at the last live hacking that
we were both at when we were sitting at this table and we were like slamming our heads into a wall
um on this one specific bug for a while um how how often do you find yourself sitting in front of a
request and trying things sort of incessantly versus sitting back staring at the ceiling and thinking
about the bug like and and i know that this is kind of a hard question because it's very um you know
abstract but just give me your gut your gut feelings on how much time you spend actually hands-on
iterating versus uh just sort of thinking and ideating yeah so so i have i have a bunch of things i i tend to
do when i i get to the point where i i can't figure it out yeah like it's all everything from you know
collecting my own kind of word list from that uh asset just to like find you know things in there that
like can make me understand what this is uh up to up to the point where where as you said like i i take a
walk and i'm like thinking about it and like how why does it behave like it does or what is it trying
to you know what data is it trying to fetch or or similar so sometimes i i would say both work
sometimes you know complete brute together with very context related information yeah like for
example generic word lists for me is not really helping that much i wouldn't say that you know word
list found on you know a really large word word list works that well i would the ones that work
are are when when you can like apply the context to what you're actually looking at that's when you're
getting the nice nice hits and and but but in in in in the other aspect also it's like sometimes you
just need to think about it and you know google error messages is like an awesome thing as well as
soon as you see an error message that is like this is not a generic error message like then you can
start digging down like maybe it's this and maybe this is the database i'm injecting into or whatever
or even maybe an error message that kind of looks like a generic error message but it's but it's not
specifically you know or it has like you know a format that is that is very very different from also
like if error messages look the same on a target and suddenly one error message doesn't that us that is also
like okay the all the other ones have you know square brackets around the error code but this one
does not like those could be also indicators that okay there's another thing causing this error message
yeah no absolutely absolutely i think like one of the really underutilized things is googling stuff
with quotes around it yeah yeah absolutely it's all the time absolutely if i see an error google something
with quotes around it and mine doesn't exactly yeah yeah exactly like that we did that at the last
event you know yeah i think what we're talking about right now it's like what is this like what
is this system what is this using what is this technology and just search the error message and
immediately there's 100 google results all mentioning the same exact thing you're like oh okay
it's okay that's that's it so last question about the hacker methodology piece so it seems like you spend a
good amount of time on your targets give me just sort of like a gut feeling on like how how much time
you spend on the average target i would say so i would say three days is is an investment first you might
not get anything from it so i've done this like short assessments kind of thing where i'm like okay i'm
gonna focus on this program and what what has happened for me is like one and a half week yeah is is is
is a it's a time for me where i know i'm gonna find something good yes i don't know how bad it will
be but i know i will find something that will be good so yeah one and a half week has been a really
good uh way for me but also like you have kids so it's like right you don't know where where you're
gonna spend that one and a half week you're gonna spend it on the night are you gonna spend it you
know in the office times or are you gonna spend it like at all like there could be you know and an
often like when you submit you know a bunch of bugs at the same time or like in the in the matter of
of days uh you always have this triage you know massage yeah yeah that is like it it can be especially
like my my reports are like sometimes two to four thousand words uh my my reports are insane man like
they are they are my blog posts are sometimes are small compared to my blog oh my god i'm writing
them manually it's not like copy pasting a boilerplate of like how it's actually like step by step
showing you know sometimes i i'm showing even how i came to the conclusion that there's there's a bug and
i have like a very long impact explanation and you know everything is like typed from from from the
from the frontal cortex yeah right 100 yeah but that's so true so but then you have so that half
week afterwards is like three triage massage basically yeah yeah yeah there's always that like getting
through yeah you get it through they find out it's not a dupe and then it's another week of yes this is
how you reproduce it yeah that's a good side effect also of going like deep into a program like compare
like live hacking events are are an exception to the to the room but but i haven't duped once in in
all like this full time since august last year uh except for live hacking you've duped me you stupid
absolutely yeah yeah like i was like yeah so like let's say for example that program right that was a
that was a challenge um and and so how long would you spend on something like that that one i spent i
to be honest that one was new for me so i didn't know what to expect so i submitted that bug only
uh and it was two hours or something yeah i mean i didn't spend on that but the funny thing was that
it was i think it was very valuable for me not to spend more time because i had a hunch that
they might not be as you know receptive to that vulnerability receptive to the report as i thought
so in in that sense i think i did a good investment not to spend more time yeah and that's also a
thing where you like especially when it comes to new programs i'm like very very restrictive on like
like the worst thing you can do is like you spend much time you find a really bad bug and then you
continue and you submit bugs and you have no response yet and you're like investing so much time
and then suddenly they respond and they don't treat you in a good way yeah and you're like why did i
continue yeah you spoke really i've heard that before from from other people in the in the in the
podcast also it's like do don't invest too much in the beginning like you won't you won't gain anything
from submitting you know 50 bugs in the beginning you're you're only gambling with your own time like
don't do that absolutely yeah you can gamble with that time when you know the receiver and you know
what what to expect from them you have to validate validate the program and validate your threat model
because on one hand you know you could be it could be the program just being right that's one possibility
you know they could just be a bad or do you have misaligned your excellent exactly exactly
think is a threat or you could have misaligned your threat model and and and that's not anybody's fault
except maybe you know one could argue that the team should have uh you know provided more insight into
their threat model sure in their policy which i would love to see more of in general but you know
like you said it's a gamble if you're not if you're not you know validating that threat model in advance
yeah because um you know it's very easy for issues to to come out of that um for sure and so okay all
right first section of my of my of my notes are are done here yes um so here's what here's where i'm
thinking we're gonna go from here okay i have uh compiled together let's see one two three four five six
uh articles some of the best hacking articles i've ever read written by franz over the years starting
in 2017 spanning all the way up to i think 2022 or 2023 the latest one um and i just want to kind of
walk through these and talk about mentality i want to talk about the technical details of them so i hope
you reviewed them because i don't know about you but i if i if i wrote something you know six months ago
and then somebody asked me about it you know six months later then i'm screwed uh because i don't
remember anything but we'll see um okay so the first one and we'll link all these in the description
as well i would it's not even something that i would recommend it is mandatory reading for any
listener of critical thinking to go and read all of these um so please keep that in mind um the first
one that i wanted to talk about was this whole uh aws s3 thing so yeah um if any you know for the
listeners here um s3 bucket takeovers and s3 bucket issues now are what it's one of the most hottest it's
one of the hottest topics in in cloud security um and all of this originates with this man right here
franz um who who sort of coined that thanks for the credit yeah the s3 bucket takeover um and so i want
to kind of you know flash back to 2017 here um you're seeing this new technology sort of coming
on the scene and you're seeing it implemented in lots of different places on all these different
programs how do you come how do you identify this issue so it was actually earlier earlier it was
actually 2014. the first the first blog post about it was in 2014 october i think yeah um and and back
then back then back then it was basically you know every time you saw a 404 you like just like moved on
yeah exactly because it's like wasn't nothing is there right uh so i i think we we came to the
conclusion like i think it was both s3 and there was some something else that was also like i think heroku
was and github github pages was one of those so i think we just came to the realization because we
were looking at like detectify was was getting built at the same time and a lot of things we were doing
was around you know finding subdomains and and trying to identify what they were running and at some
point i think we we figured out that like okay so uh we started signing up on these these uh you know
providers i think it was shopify as well like this this sauce services and suddenly realized that you
could just like there were no verification at all like we were under the like assumption in the
beginning that you need to validate your your that you own the domain because that's how you do you
know everything else when it comes to like gmail or you know when you want to run gmail for example
and and and and and realize that okay nobody's actually doing this because it's like a convenience
thing yeah to to like not use that validation part and we started reaching out to all these companies
and writing like okay somebody can just hijack all these these uh companies uh because they're pointing
to you and some of these some of the providers were just like yeah but they're not our customer anymore
so why oh my gosh reading between the lines that was what they were saying like it's not our fault that
you know they're not paying us anymore or you know you mean somebody's gonna have to pay us to hack
them i like that it's not our customer yeah yeah go for it no but so so i think and and and a lot of
them were like we already know about this this is no no big deal and and we were we were screaming
loud like please do something about it like add the validation do you know whatever like something
you need to do something and and when everybody responded like not a single company responded with
like yeah you're right oh my gosh we we realized like we need to get it get it out there and then
it was just a matter of like how many more are they and i think the first blog post we had we had
like 14 maybe providers like big providers that we decided to to announce uh but at the same time there
were you know a huge amount popping up since then of course still popping up to this day and uh and s3 is
one of those that that like keeps on lingering uh i know that there are there are some changes happening
or like you can't change s3 but you can you can do implementations above it that is like safe so
there's something called s3 access points which is uh their addition to it and access points always
get like a unique um hash in the in it so you can't reclaim an access point so that's that's like aws
solution to the problem is to like make access point the the way to actually access a bucket um but
yeah i think and like one of the big challenges in the beginning also when it comes to s3 was to figure
out what the bucket name was it wasn't always clear even though you have it in the error message it
wasn't always clear uh what the bucket and especially sometimes you do want to know the bucket name even if
it's uh exists and i think that was the the whole idea with the bucket this close was to figure out
what the bucket was named because if you knew what the bucket was named you can make additional api calls
on the side uh to that bucket to see access level errors and stuff yeah that's that's such an amazing
little little script there um yeah and we'll link it down below yeah we'll link it down below and it does
still work to allow you to identify what the name of a bucket is and there's lots of really cool error
based stuff you can do with that too where you're like creating um invalid signed urls that fail in
such a specific way that it like leaks the bucket name so cool we have the same i love this me and
matthias built the same one in the beginning of this year for uh google cloud storage nice so we have
uh we have seven seven the cloaking methods for for uh for uh cloud storage and it's kind of helpful
in cloud storage as well because sometimes you really want to know the name yeah and it's very
important for depending on how your setup looks like so i think i will talk with matthias to get it
out as well i think it's very fun to have that's awesome decloaking i love the the that like terminology
yes i think this applies to more than just s3 buckets where like this is it's very similar to
like origin server yeah detection where you know if you're trying to bypass a waft for example yeah
you find what the origin server is or a way to talk to the origin server directly and mimic is if your
requests are going through the wrap waft then oftentimes you can just bypass the waft directly
and it's very similar to like s3 where you might have some sub domain that's maybe it's talking to a
backend service instead of actually just being a c name um to the bucket directly and if you can figure
out some way to air it or you know get get it to basically oracle to what the bucket is then you
can you know maybe read some data that you shouldn't have access to you can list the bucket maybe you
can do you know whatever it really depends on the context yes i love that that methodology the decloaking
is is applicable in so many aspects like you mentioned as well like with a reverse proxy or an
origin structure you know if you can leak that back end url there's there's a decent chance that you
might be able to use that in a vhost you know somewhere else at a load balancer level and hit that
back end server directly and just bypass all of the middleware authentication that they've got in place
so we've seen that time and time again and it's a it's an awesome technique and and that's another one
of the things that kind of comes out of the security research is is the the impact the the conceptual
impact is very wide-reaching right yeah it's applicable to lots of different areas which is which
is really cool um okay so there's lots of other stuff you can dive into with this with this blog post
that will link the and actually i didn't even have the one i'm looking back now because you said
there's one in 2014 and then there's also another one which i missed in 2016 where you're talking about
cloud front stuff and um oh yeah and oh that was fun yeah that was good memories and the the the uh
the trailing dot dude yeah like oh yeah there was a bug there was a bug like in a live hacking event
right yeah just like two years ago or something that that one of the bugs the best bugs in that live
hacking event was a trailing dot yeah so it still happened so for those of you excuse me for those
of you that don't know about that actually you know franz why don't you tell them a little bit about
trailing dot and what that does conceptually yeah so i think the the blog post mentions specifically
cloudfront so what happened with cloudfront was that when you went to in this case it was like
paypal.com it wasn't paypal.com i think it was car.com so you went to car.com and you would be
served a page through cloudflare uh but the whole idea with like how internet works or like the dub dub
dub works was that uh you can always add a trading cloudflare or cloudfront cloudfront cloudfront okay
yes out front yeah yeah you can always add like a trailing dot to a domain yeah because that's the
it's called like fqd and like a fully qualified domain name is actually ending with a dot
uh they've just removed it for like i think for like simplicity or something yeah so a trailing dot
should always you know serve similar things or just give an error or whatever and in cloudfront it gave
an error but it gave the error that looked like nobody has claimed that domain so i went into cloudfront
now you can't do this anymore because cloudfront wants you to validate that you own the domain but
back then you could just add it as a c name to cloudfront and it had like a client side validation
so you couldn't add a trailing dot it would say you can't but if you'd like capture the proxy
if you take the like it was like a g g rpc request and you modified that little thing in the request with
a dot you would add that to your to your own host and then you could serve whatever you want on the on
the trailing dot and funny thing was that cloudfront has cookie logging so it will log your cookies also
and cookies are working both on the fqdn and the regular domain so if you had cookies sign into paypal
and our car.com and then went to car.com dot you would i would get your cookies um and i started
getting those logs and i saw like people were clicking on emails and then i realized why are they
getting this from clicking on emails because they write please hello my dear friend go to car.com dot
and then the dot would be you know included in the link because i mean it's a link right
uh so that was the reason why so many came to the dot domain because it was like in in the end of a
sentence wow so this doesn't even really require user interaction at that point because people are
just going to that domain native yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah so that was that was the scary
part uh and and it was a long process from that part like paypal obviously fixed it by by reclaiming
it themselves yeah but then it was a long discussion with aws also getting them to like you know you
need to normalize this and so they also treated this as a as a bug themselves wow do you feel like a
lot of the bugs that you found have led to those sweeping sort of aws changes like yeah yes yes yes
i do like one of one of the one of the things that i i talked a lot on i had a oasper event uh talking
about the dns and route 53 uh and and suddenly they took a took a couple of years but they fixed it
and that is one of the most impressive patches i've ever seen like i have no i like i dream of the
day somebody tells me how that mitigation was done it's like seriously like yeah it's impressive as hell
they do they do they do something out of the out of the box thinking there they really do and i've
tried me and shubs and plenty of other hackers have spent so much time trying to bypass that mitigation
because if you can there's a treasure trove of bugs uh there you know being able to reclaim these
these domains um but yeah that dude that was a sad day for me man whenever they fixed that that bug
because that was my that was my cash cow when i was in in uh in you know automation also have these
you know oh now the curve going down right it happens in automation as well especially yeah i think
it punches you harder when those things happen in automation i i i forgot to say that but but when
automation gets when something happened with your automation and goes like that that's a panic you
don't want to end up with like that panic is worse worse than having a vacation and you go you see it go
down absolutely 100 especially when you've dumped so much time into a technique like i spent
weeks you know months of actual time you know like hands on the keyboard time refining my my route 53
flow and and just to be clear route 53 takeovers are still possible in some capacity but um it's it's
very limited in comparison yeah yeah and so um definitely changed a lot and and that was yeah that
was the day the day the music died for me that was the that was the day that that i was like you know
what i think i'm done with this um and so yeah all right so man i missed so many articles you know
when i when i just going back i just kind of cherry picked some of my my frog you know favorite moments
but now i'm sure you know why i post post things because the bugs turn boring after a while right so
yeah this is this is my outlet to like eliminate me from looking at them anymore because i hope that
someone else will look for them yeah that sounds pretty i was gonna ask if you take notes but it's it's
my yeah that's true but it's my way of like moving forward like if i if i out like myself in the way
that like like my secret tricks if i just get them out there i can move on finding new new things yeah
it pushes me forward and that's amazing for the community too what a benefit and and friends can i
ask i mean do you do you like writing in particular like do you would you say that you enjoy writing yeah
i think i think it's a necessity almost since i spend so much time on like writing reports yeah
however like it's hard for me to like sit down and say now i'm gonna skip hacking and now i'm gonna
write the uh you know a blog post about something because as what often happens is like i'm not writing
a short little blog post on what i did yesterday it's like it's gonna be like a huge article and i need
like i have one here that that i'm i'm still cooking on it's been cooking since january and i
know for a fact that i like i can't start you know directly going at it i need i need to explain a lot
of before i can come to the to the conclusion of what i found and it's gonna take it's gonna take a
week two weeks maybe yeah and it's gonna be painful like a lot a big part of writing blog posts for
me is like painful painful you know going back and realize how hard everything was or how long it took
and like i really want to emphasize that also in the latest blog post i have it's like it's a big
focus on how much pain goes into like weight like spending that time and it's great that you mentioned
that because i will and and i'm not sure if you're talking because you mentioned just a second ago you
you you you had a blog post you're working on i think yesterday so i'm very interested to pick your
brain on that but um i'm i'm talking i'm talking about um the account hijacking using dirty dancing
one one of my notes for that one and it's on the list that we'll talk about later but that that blog
post is so beautiful because it talks about the ups and downs of doing security research right yeah and
it talks about like this whole concept of well you know these gadgets you know it needed to leak
these tokens and stuff like that the stars have to align in so many ways for these to be there and
and absolutely and when you go out there and you're like man i feel like this might be a systemic issue
you're challenging something and you're in your you're betting against the odds there and you're
really like putting yourself out there by spending a ton of time to assess so many different different
things and i think it's great that you represented it that way in the in the article and i i think not
to not to destroy the discussion later about it but uh one big thing with that the the whole the whole
idea about like my whole theory was not based on finding that bug yeah like i had zero bugs such for
such a long time i didn't even have one you know i i had zero bugs i just had a theory that oh this
would be so beautiful if if you could get this working like i had a discussion in the office here
i came here like yeah i'm i'm having a like a theory i'm working on but i don't know if it's gonna work
like this is my idea and if this works then maybe like crazy right and then and i'm like i had nothing
so so that was it was such a gamble it was it was 100 the gamble on like let's then go look for it
like how like i had no idea how to do it so that was very painful also in the in the way of like oh i'm
really trying to as you said like getting the stars to align but then suddenly like one of the my my
favorite programs turned out to have that thing that that was the like the trigger that okay there
i i'm right like there is something here can i come up with other you know idea gadgets or whatever so
everything came out of ideas not from uh like real life that was the big difference with that blog post
all other blog posts are based on reality first and then i'm moving backwards trying to like see a
systemic issue about it this was 100 idea trying to squeeze it in it like very fitted into 10 years
since the blog post i learned from like everything was aligned like can i can i write a good oas blog
post 10 years after my idols wrote one that would be that would be so it was very much like i
really need to find a way for this to work so yeah so when you're like approaching stuff like we've
talked a little bit about this sort of like the really out of the box type of thinking versus the
like more like data driven context driven developer driven type of methodology do you
do you like going down that route of more just like maybe this is happening or do you find that it
doesn't really pay off most of the time so it doesn't pay off a lot of the times and so i i mentioned
the google cloud storage the cloak like that was the whole idea with that research was to find
systemic issues around that like we found some of them but they weren't you know i wouldn't say you
couldn't execute them in bug bounty programs uh you could maybe execute them you know if you want to
uh report things to google but but for google in google's aspect they wouldn't be like really bad
bugs they would be like coincidental misconfigures together with like odd you know confident like
all the configurations for google but also for the customer using them and stuff but so that turned out
to be like we don't really have anything we have a decloak tool maybe that could be fun to blog about
maybe we can do like a decloak blog post talking about the the ways we found this decloaking mechanisms
and and maybe that could be interesting like now i'm like now i'm forcing myself to write these blog
posts because it would be weird talking about the blog post that i i would read so do you i mean you
mentioned before one motivation for writing the blog post is you know it gets it out of your head
and allows you to move on to something different so i i think that's a really great takeaway
um i wanted to ask about because you're releasing all of these on detectify um you know on the
detectify blog um and and so is that an intentional decision is that to help you know detectify build
brand recognition because let me just provide some context from from my perspective as a hacker like
you know i i don't use detectify i'm not i'm not an organization you know where i could use detectify
but my respect for detectify is like you know very high because of all this super high quality research
same sort of thing you see with acid know right where they're constantly putting out high quality
research um yeah so you know besides the motivation of of um you know getting it out of your head what
are some other motivations that you have for doing the blog posts and hosting them on detectify
i think i think one important aspect is like they i've been a part of it for so long so it's important
for me to like uh i respect like i respect the whole team so much that i want to show them that
that it's like very important part of who i am and where i'm at as well as like sometimes i actually
like me and frederick sometimes collaborate on blog posts and he's he's you know uh working here uh from
day to day as well so i think it's like this office for me is a very good way of uh doing
you know uh what's it called like brainstorming and things like trying to figure out things so
often most often uh i i tend to present it to them first what i'm thinking about sure and then
because of the knowledge here i can get like feedback on like maybe you should do this maybe
you should do that or maybe you should call it dirty dancing uh which was like that's great
like emily in the office like you should call it it's like sounds like dirty dancing to me like yeah
yeah that's that's a good name so i i think that it's very helpful having a context nearby where
where a lot of people know exactly what you're talking about and and you know the technology so
i think that's that's very helpful also like i'm i'm obviously still a part of the text by right not
not that i'm writing any code and i shouldn't right but but it's it's and i think also like
i i don't have a big gain i think on like making my own personal blog and creating a name out of that
i'm more than happy to like attach myself to a company that i that i value and and like i'm a part of
much more than than doing it you know privately trying to build a brand and you kind of get a
two for one when you do it because i mean i don't know maybe maybe it's just the fact that your brand
is already established you know in the in the community right um but uh you know when we when
we look at this blog post and we say okay detectify is releasing this but franz is writing it you know
you kind of get um you know it's almost like to put it in seo terms it's almost like you get domain
authority on on detectify and you get you know community authority from franz so it's a good it's
a good it's a good thing and man when i'm thinking about where to go next here there's so many you
know we could go down the route of like let's talk about about dirty dancing we could talk about uh you
know hackering plus entrepreneurship and i think that that is where i want to go with this next one
which is like so you you go you come into this company you know you started detectify with you know
years ago with with you know matthias and and em all based off of you know uh that security research
what what role do you play in this company and like what because to me it kind of seems like
you just kind of run around and you're like hey guys what if we did this blog post and like what if
like have you seen this cool technical idea and like who the heck are you to this company like so
it's a good that you say that because like one of the things happening with the companies that i
i've built when they are growing up there is like a big discussion on like how do we squeeze france
into the regular you know day-to-day basis like what can we do so i was i was a scrum what was i
called i was uh like a scrum master right there no scrum breakers come break okay so i went in and
like we should do this and like the whole scrum team is like we hate you so i was i was the scrum
breaker and and and so and every time when when it gets like more than 40 50 people it's like how do
we fit this weird person individual into this organization and it's like yeah how do you how did
you so one of the things that i find really difficult and even just the small entrepreneurial
endeavors that i've been a part of is delegating like and so when you started these companies have
you had other players that are you know the executive players from the very beginning or how do
you how was it hard for you to give up control or delegate um you know jobs to different people and
how did you move out of that okay so i i could say like this one of the benefits i had was to have
a business partner early on that was very much into sales and also into managing that's awesome uh i
think that was the helpful part so i always had to you know take the technical jacket on and and and be
the one in both in charge of the team doing the technical things but also together with the team trying
to figure out how to solve certain things like in the beginning it was me building you know building
uh everything and then we we got like our first employee that was a developer and we we we worked
really well together with so we could start building it uh also like this was an e-commerce platform it's
still alive it's called centra it was smaller than it's bigger now uh but but so when we started building
centra uh we uh i was always down on the floor so to say i was always a part of the team that was like my
whole concept of like uh my my way of managing in the technical team was to be just one one of the
guys like i was never you know doing any salary talks that was never my my my job i was not doing
any one and once so one of ones was done by someone else i was the you know cto in the way that like i'm
gonna play with new technologies i'm gonna try to execute them if i can love something and i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna together with the team like sometimes make a smaller team out of the bigger team just
to make something reality as fast as possible but that thing only works when you go up to like when
we we turn into 50 or 60 people that's when it's like really hard to like take some people out of
the dev team and get to do some fun new thing and then trying to move them put them back again and like
everybody's happy like that that's not how it works so it it became really hard for me to like squeeze
like be squeezed in and like get to play with the fun toys uh so i i've come to the realization that like
i can i can build i'm i'm really good at like starting from zero yeah and then when when we we get up to
40 50 people i'm like yeah just roll it out of the picture yeah yeah exactly that's that's basically
yeah and i think it's good for everyone if i do that because else it's just so much politics around
i love how he says that else else is this you know like else then that's literally the program
exception is making it into the verbiage that's that's amazing um yeah yeah that so i think that's
that's the the the aspect of it is is yeah yeah i don't know if that was an answer to the question
it is man it it's it's a great i mean what a great position to be in what a dream of a position
and i think so many people that have the entrepreneurial itch that are also technical
people dream of positions like that of like okay i'm i'm c-suite you know i i have influence on this
organization but all the crappy stuff like sales and management i'm gonna just not do that and i'm
gonna do that i'm gonna we all know that this is how it works best too when you're operating in your
area of expertise when you're operating in your passion so that just highlights the the importance of
trying to find someone who who you know that's a partner that's very passionate about sales and
and management and that sort of thing so that you each can operate in your own sort of you know
expertise yeah exactly yeah i also love that like co-founder model where like it's really hard to be
good at everything i think it's much more of an anomaly to be good at like both aspects of the
business like both the technical and like the the the really refined like fine point like how does the
product or feature service or whatever actually work versus like getting it sold and like getting
customers and getting it marketed and that kind of stuff and trying to balance both of those things
as one person is really really difficult um and oftentimes you either have to subsidize that
temporarily by like either taking debt or using your own personal money to like pay people to do
that or you get just like drowned in doing everything by yourself and every single day is like a 12 to 16
hour day just like yeah doing sales and also writing the product and also sending emails and yeah doing
like everything at once and so if you can start out by having that balance it's just like really but it's
not that i it's not that we realized that to begin with like i had salary talks but the only thing
happening was that i raised everybody's salary like way too much so it's like we we came like we we had a
gift no more salary talks for franz no and i had we had like a christmas gift thing and we were like
giving away iphones and it's like oh my god we had so little money on on the first day of the year
afterwards and it was like maybe i shouldn't do this uh i should not be the one in charge of like
because i wanted everybody happy like that was my because yeah so i i came into this podcast thinking
franz is like some hacker entrepreneurial genius and now i'm leaving thinking frauds is running around
annoying people until he doesn't have to do the parts of the job that he doesn't want him to
probably yeah that's true i guess but it's like yeah i mean there's some truth also to like
uh we we kind of realized like where where do where is my execution the best like the best place to be
in and like that that was the that was the way to like grow very fast i make a joke about that but
but but really you know it that's the wisest thing to do truly yeah and and so um yeah there's there's
i guess one of this is more of a personal question for for from my perspective one of the things i've
struggled with is is you know releasing that and being like all right you know i actually just need
to delegate this job to someone else yeah and and the reason why i struggle with that is because it's
like okay well a lot of times in the beginning that means giving up equity right and and because you don't
have the money or if you do have the money you don't want to you know i don't know just sink all of
your life savings into a thing which actually you hear about entrepreneurs doing all the time which
is just you know awesome and inspiring um i mean is that is that what you what you had to do i mean is
that what is that what you need to do is you just need to give give the equity so that you don't have
to do this part of the job and that's the right decision from your perspective i i wouldn't say
say we had to do that from the get-go at all uh to begin with but we came i think uh our our
perspective of it has changed because of experience like in the beginning we could actually you know
with a salary get people engaged and get people to actually do things and build and have fun like we
had a lot of fun building these companies because it was so much hands-on we were like out there we were
you know i was developing things next to the customers you know at like there was a big like
spectacle around you know how we how we did business in the beginning uh but but then i think um i lost
the thread uh yeah yeah what was the question well the question is is like i guess at the end of the day
what i need you to tell me is oh yeah capital to give to to delegate these jobs right so so what happened
what happened then was that i uh when it comes to uh oh i had it yeah it came and then i lost it and
it's funny i i get the same sort of things when i'm in these situations on a podcast in particular
because it's so hard i had so much to explain there but it's like i lost it i i think i think it's it
yeah so what happened was that we got people employed without like giving away actual equity because
we both had a really fun place to be at because of the spectacle but also because they like we were
paying a fair kind of salary yeah but then we like during all these years and i think also it's like
uh uh like how the society works like there's a much more talk now about you know getting equity
when you're building a startup and stuff and we we never we never really called ourselves a startup
because we we made money from day one so we we never you know had a problem with the you know uh
money wise uh but that's but i think that's an important delimitant uh you know that that's an
important factor there because if you're making money from day one if you build your mvp and you
actually have that validated by by receiving money then all of these issues of like start start to
disappear because at the end of the day you can just hire someone and pay them you know exactly because
you you you do have the money but then i mean a lot of a lot of the money i made in bug bounties have
been invested into these companies so we all we had that all we didn't have that from the beginning
because that that wasn't how it worked in the beginning but but during during all these years we
had that as a kind of a way to solve a bunch of problems with money obviously yeah but but but then we
also realized that a lot of people that that stayed for a really long time it was much more valuable
for them and for us to give them equity and a part of the company yeah so that that that happened
after a longer while but now it's like almost you know a standard thing like if you join a startup
you're getting a a part of the equity in some form of you know um like a pool similar uh equity pool and
uh but but back then it wasn't and i think that was helpful also into like
you know coming getting into that but but i would say like what what happened now later on with you
know getting a a ceo for example like we we didn't want to be the ceo of this company so we we you know
found or the ceo found us in those cases it's always you know you need to give up equity obviously
because you you want them to be like you know they have to be fully on you know active on on getting the
company to to where everybody else wants wants it but uh so i i would say it depends on what kind of
position you want to fill or what kind of things you like you don't need to give away equity for
for every every single you know person that joins unless you yeah like you can find some good money
yeah yeah that's true but i mean you can find some some nice equity pooling kind of things where you get
like uh you know investing time and stuff so you know that people stay at least that time like
but but it all matters if you if you have like very key positions like then then that discussion
is relevant so so i i wanted to ask one more thing and and i think you know critical thinking is a
podcast focused specifically on bug bounty hunting so the entrepreneurial piece of this while is
absolutely fascinating to me and i think many of our listeners share that interest um i think i may
move a lot more of my entrepreneurial questions into a different segment that maybe we'll release under
the premium discord channel or something like that um but uh one last thing that i wanted to ask about
this was when you were taking bug bounty money and and putting it into the companies how were you
thinking about that mentally were you thinking about that as this is franz's money that he's investing into
the company or were you thinking i'm working for the company and i'm i'm generating this income that is
just getting direct directly put right into the company yeah so what what happened was we me and my
business partner we're 50 50 and uh this was my way of uh providing so what i did was providing quick
capital sure like monetary wise the capital yeah but he was building like he he's he was in charge of
being the ceo and and everything in the beginning so so he was in charge of building the company you
know making the company more valuable but i was bringing in the quick bucks to actually make it
you know much more uh easy to solve problems and to scale easier yeah yeah it's a scale easier so so
we we both agree that like we're putting in different things but we need to align somewhere here where
like it's fine for me and still fine for him and like i think it's a weird balance also especially
when when the bug bounty is like you can go from one month you're getting you know this amount and and
a live hacking event you get this amount yeah yeah and it it turned really complex in the end and it
turned turns into a lot of money if you're if you're good at what you're doing so uh i think it in the end
it it was probably like we we don't have that this this uh setup anymore uh and i i think that's that's
probably for the best because it can clearly like misalign you know interests 100 time especially when
it when it when it you know now we've got a bug bounty company where franz does hacking and then we pay
employees you know like yeah yeah no it's complex is franz's bugs yeah exactly it's like like bug
hunting as a sir i don't know what to call it yeah it's like funding by bug bounty hunting yeah for
sure um okay so we'll we'll i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and cross off my uh hacking plus entrepreneurial
section here um thank you for those awesome insights franz that's that's awesome and and i know you and
i have had some personal chats you know from time to time about uh entrepreneurial ship entrepreneurship
plus um that's a good one what was it was automation entrepreneurship um no uh you know plus hacking so
uh definitely a lot of wisdom to be received there um bringing us back on track to the to the hacking
stuff i did want to talk about one of my favorite um talks that you've ever done which just essentially
looked like prophecy to me looking back in in the past which is your attacking modern web technologies
talk that you did in 2018 um almost exactly five years ago yeah um and attacking modern web technologies
there were so many awesome pieces to this there was um app caches and service workers uh you know
there was post message stuff there was i mean yeah the the policies the s3 policies all sorts of stuff
all over the place so um once again mandatory mandatory reading for anybody who's listening
um the crazy thing about to me about this talk is like this is still the stuff that we're talking about
today like yeah and this was five years ago right yes it's still applicable yeah yeah i find bugs
like like sometimes i need to go back to those slides because i find bugs for those things exactly they
have extremely long lifespan those blog posts yeah i'm surprised myself that it's like still working
and this is something that's really i think a key listen and also help helps for your for your brand
as well franz is that franz was was talking about this stuff not not only doing this stuff but talking
about it publicly in 2018 five years ago and i i we talk about post message still being an underserved
technology even to this day so keep an eye on anything franz releases because it it will very likely be
applicable for the future um uh so talk to me a little bit about uh app cache and and service worker
stuff and then um in conjunction with that the beauty of the synergies between cookie stuffing and and
these technologies yeah so i think the the the interesting part with the app cache uh that that
happened there there were there were many many fun things with it but my aspect of it was that i had
uh really old dropbox account and the old dropbox account were like grandfathered into
a place where you could actually host websites on on dropbox user content.com and you and if you
created a new dropbox account back then you couldn't really run your own like you couldn't render
html pages and stuff but if you had a legacy dropbox account you could but it was very limited
into what you could actually trigger with it or like get it to to render um and i came to the conclusion
that like what can i do with an xss or running an xss on on dropbox user content and i i remember i was
talking with matthias then and like what can we do like can we do something and we came to the conclusion
like okay cookie stuffing we can do so you can make it like unable to actually load because you're
filling up the cookie jar so much so when you're making a request later on it will fail so so question
here so essentially what was happening is you were able to host your uh you know attacker controlled
content on a domain with with other attack you know victim content on on that same domain right yeah
exactly what happened was you got like a user directory on dropbox user content that you could
host data on uh and then you could uh i think it was that whenever you see it now and i'll reference
it it's slide 15 for any of those of you that are following along here um you know he's got dl
dropbox user content.com slash you and then the user id and then wherever you would update stuff and
you got the xss not by uploading an html file but by using svg yeah well i think it was an xml xml xml
yeah right you're right yes xml yeah so that was the thing uh everything else was like you know
getting downloaded and position attachment uh but that was the way but but if you had a new dropbox
account you would never get the url to to uh you dropbox user user content it was only the legacy
dropbox account that's really had that feature enabled um so that was the you know the the weird
part first with with having that so we knew that we could do cookie stuffing and what would happen
then if if somebody else sent a link that would like 404 and or a four of four of five or something
or five five zero something four eleven uh i think yeah actually yeah yeah so so that concept of of um
um cookie stuffing i learned that from from you and from file descriptor and and so i think it was my
descriptor that that i learned it from it was from i was gonna ask where did you get that knowledge and
of course it goes back to another legend file descriptor yeah file descriptor man and and the
funny thing with this bug was that i think matthias was the one meant we're coming back to file descriptor
so yeah he mentioned app cache and i started reading up on what app cache was doing and matthias as well
and we started like playing with that and realized that we could you know host reference a manifest in
in the xml file that manifest would then be loaded and that manifest could be like a regular text or
whatever sure and that text could contain and say that if if you're unable to reach this website
you should have a fallback your fallback page of this and that sure because the whole app cache thing
was based on you running an app and you're going offline with your cell phone so you need to if
you reload the page you can still visit this is crazy and absolutely crazy and what happened was
that we realized that in our user path we could put an html file or an xml file and we could say that
this is the one that should be loaded if you can't reach the website and then we realized okay does the
cookie stuffing result in this thing and it turns out that yes so we cookie stuffed and made sure that if
you clicked on any other link we would just steal the url and then steal the the page of that signed
url ourselves that's amazing but the weird part of was that when we did this blog post i don't know
exactly date wise so our bug to dropbox was here and then here yeah and then file descriptor comes out
with a talk uh explaining this bug and we were like but we what we what so that that was when we wanted
we got the dropbox uh bug published so we could show that we also figured this out that's crazy
and and so so he actually did a talk on i think on the oas the oas talk or or something else but
and so we like we came to the same kind of conclusion uh which was great so i wanted to like highlight
that that like sometimes people can like figure out the same kind of things at the same time
uh and as you mentioned uh like there's like the new thing i i think i mentioned it as well like
service workers was a was a like a replacement for appcache but back then i think it was like very hard
to like get the service worker to work because yeah you needed to have like a specific header on the
service worker file to allow it to run as a service worker and there were a lot of like if this and that's
that that had to work uh to make it actually yeah it seems like there's there's definitely been some
change in that area now and so um you know i've definitely seen service workers used in in lots of
different different contexts i believe you and i i always have to you know go back and look at it but
i'm not 100 sure but i i'm 99 sure that service workers can be installed without a header now
and the header that if you do supply an http response header what that will allow you to do is
reassign the uh the root existing the the um authority for that service worker so if you you
know even though you're installing the service worker at like slash js slash sj.js or whatever or sw.js
um yeah then you know you would normally just have authority for the slash js directory but if you're
able to serve that service worker allowed i think header um then you can get uh and say hey give it
permission to slash then you can now affect all the resources around everywhere um and it's it's such an
interesting technology especially when you pair it with something like uh subdomain takeover or or um you
know file upload because you can gain sort of sort of a persistence in the browser as well um using service
workers and and um you know that that we've seen this also with uh truffle security released a tool
called of cores i'm not sure if you've seen it franz but it's it's um it uses a service worker in the
background to uh gain more time to be able to attack different um websites that have vulnerable course
configurations even if you just visit the page for just an instant you know so there's so many um
um i think applicable uh you know exploitation scenarios for service workers um that that we we
got to keep our eye on because they have tremendous impact yeah no and i agree but like i i guess the
core concept first is like you need to have an xss to begin with yes and and then you probably need to
have arguments on why that xss wasn't important in the beginning and i guess like storage like a bucket
storage is a it's a it's a good argument on like an xss there doesn't do anything but if you have
persistence you can like show and i think that was what the the the bug showed was like it's a sandbox
domain it doesn't have any impact but you have persistence and and and that's the way to like gain
access to other urls and stuff i just thought about something franz you know one of the things we're
going to talk about a little bit later assuming we don't have to cut for time is this middleware
misconfigurations yeah that you you talked about so what if we changed that right like we we changed
the middleware misconfiguration um and and so now we we can use that to hit a different bucket on the
so just to be i'm going to give the tldr of the of the middleware misconfiguration thing if you if you
essentially with some nginx configurations if you hit it if you put a bunch of escape characters you know
um new lines and stuff like that in the url and they have to have some specific proxy pass rules
um then you will be able to re rewrite the rest of the request and hit other s3 buckets or other
back-end entities and host your own content exactly so what if we we changed that with service workers
right um where you could then hit your own s3 bucket and an issue but i'm wondering i mean you
still have stored stored xss i guess like somebody needs to visit your url still
and and that one would still make you host whatever content you want on that website so
but the the thing you're getting is the the persistent thing right you can actually make it
load but they still need to visit it once can you can you i'm wondering though can you
set response headers in s3 yeah it depends if it's s3 website you can some of them uh but i mean
you could also if it's s3 website you can still redirect it to whatever like and depending on like
the csp for example you can still redirect it elsewhere i don't know if that helps you though no
no because what i'm thinking is like wouldn't it be cool if we could insert some some new line
characters overwrite the the backend bucket right have the bucket serve a a service worker and then
insert the service worker header to slash so now so we we we gain you know that service worker
authority um and get xss stored xss on every single page that the user visits within the browser i think
that could be really i mean s3 website would allow you to do this if it's if the s3 website uh is if
it's proxying you to s3 website and you can inject something to modify what bucket it's gonna serve as a
a website you can inject whatever it depends on the host because i wonder i wonder if if we are
hitting so let's say they're sending a request to you know whatever dot s3.amazonaws.com and then we
overwrite the host header on that i wonder if it uses that same load balancer origin ip for you to
insert a header to hit s3 websites like if you if you put in it doesn't okay no uh s3 website is also
quirky because it only responds on http and not https oh what uh i have no idea why i think it has
something to do with like you're supposed to put it behind something else kind of cloud front or
whatever but so they they don't have the same load balancer and you can't really get to s3 website
from s3 as far as i know it weird yeah that's that's definitely it's very isolated it's like a totally
it's like an overlay over s3 it's like s3 website is like its own thing that renders whatever you
want basically yeah we'll definitely have to research that a little bit more the the other
area that i was thinking that this could be interesting is with crlf injection uh and into
the response headers right if you can do response splitting assign the service worker a loud header then
you can make a service worker out of the response planning yeah sure that would be pretty
you need something to load it i mean you could probably make two crlf one crlf to load a fake
document and one crlf that loads a fake service worker with the header to install it absolutely that
should work yeah sure that's that's that's some good that's some good shit right there um that's fun
then you get persistence yeah huh i'm just interesting i'm thinking about all the possibilities
playing with it i can see the gears turning yeah as soon as he hangs up he's gonna he's got three
programs he's gonna go look at then you then you and then you can probably you know escalate it to
you know steal access tokens and stuff and yeah i mean you can probably do things with that and it
makes it a lot more it makes it i mean it's a little bit interesting right because technically what
that could result in then is we could get plain we could leak the user's plain text password without
user interaction right because i like you said what what are we actually what do we actually gain
from this because at that point if we have stored xss right then we can just open up whatever pages
we want in an iframe and then do whatever we want right and do whatever yeah but but one of the things
that we can't do is is without more entry user interaction is leak the user's plain text password
assuming they don't have any crazy thing yeah but but due to the persistence you can uh you can get
them to yeah sure which which really escalates pretty much any and then i guess it's a reflected
more than uh stored but you turn it into more of a stored client-side store yeah yeah a client-side
stored xss that's that's really interesting and then and then this this is a really good um ato
mechanism because some especially if you then proceed to cookie bomb like a a specific path
that that issues you know an auth token or something like that it forces the user to to clear their
cookies and re-auth the next time that they go into the application and at that point if you've got the
service worker you can hijack the the plain text password yeah we get that this is some good i didn't
get you on this podcast more often for this is great no no this is really good okay so um wow as
much as i would like to sit there and just uh think on that for the next little while let's let's try to
keep rolling um it's probably a sin but i'm going to skip this whole uh section on um s3 policies and
cloud policy uploads which is a really awesome part of of the attacking modern web technologies uh talk and
i'm going to jump to something that we've talked a little bit more about on the podcast uh often
which is um the the post message stuff um yeah so uh how did you because i once again you're one of the
one of the first people that i i you know sort of introduced me to post message stuff yeah where
where did you how did you come up with this and then what what was it like you know sort of seeing this
did somebody else's research spur this thought in you or was it just how does this work no sort of
eyes that's that's a really good do you remember i guess it's the first no i i don't i actually don't
100 remember yeah where i i think i think like this i think there were examples of vulnerable cases
already sure like i wasn't the one showing that you can exploit it uh but i started to
to so i think i did a lot of focus back then on i think it was dropbox sure maybe yeah and i think it
was so it was also like payment providers there was something because payment providers tend to do a lot
of and you had to talk yourself about it yeah yeah and and what happened was that there was a as a as a
huge amount of payment providers that started moving over to post message
post message and you always had a really hard part finding all the post message listeners so as i did
back then i was discussing with matthias like how how do we figure these things out and and we came to
the conclusion that like okay probably an extension and then i sat down and wrote a bunch of like
you know inside iframes deep you know post message that that get listeners that get triggers by
actions and and a lot of different i think it's still in the repository there's like an example
dot html with a bunch of listeners and and just to like try to figure out what we can do about it and
i i made my first uh version of the of the extension and like okay this will be usable like oh just the
number even though you have like five iframes deep a listener the number counter on the post message
listener chrome extension would still you know increase versus looking at the the source uh
events global events and you only see the iframe you're currently selected yeah i was like this is
a terrible functionality uh so i made my first version of this and i i talked with the google team
because i told them like why can't you just like i don't want to start building an extension like can't
you just fix so you can see all the listeners in all iframes yeah and they're like no this is how
it's supposed to be and blah blah blah and it's terrible and it's something that i talked about
in my talk as well but like yeah you got to do your do in in you still even have to do your due
diligence to go and show where all of the you know to to go assess all of the listeners because
something may not be utilizing that listener right so in that case it won't show up in post message
tracker so you've still got to go through and do it one of the in you know it's my fault is as well
because i haven't contributed to that nice private repo you put me on for for post message tracker but
i think it would be really cool to to add a a line that that shows every time a post message tracker is
registered and where it's registered so you so you you know just like you get a request where you know
you get a log in your console when it gets sent through um when a post message is sent through you
can also get a log when one is registered so you can know okay well the you know my
child windows third iframe has registered a launched yeah yeah a listener that that could be really cool
because that attack surface is all over the place like you mentioned absolutely and and i would say
the most common ones i found nowadays are the ones not initiated from from start but by action yeah so
they they just because you so i have an example in one talk i did on in amsterdam for like a live
hacking event basically what happened was that when you clicked on upload document there was a listener
started at that action and then you could do whatever you could basically read whatever document
you uploaded you could read it from the sandbox uh but but so there's a bunch of those like action
based listeners that gets triggered by things and what i've seen late like lately also i think one of
the biggest tricks that up my sleeve with the post message listener was the unpacking of the rappers
yeah so basically everything is wrapped through new relic or roll bar or there's a bunch of those but
and jquery also has its own wrapper but the way of figuring out how to bypass the wrapper and then go
directly to the function so you can get like the real function that is actually being triggered that
was i think the the golden nugget in in the extension that is that that was really helpful and what i've
seen lately now is like people using message ports which is like an addition to to post message where
you send an initial post message with the port and that port can then be you know you can shuffle that
port between iframes uh but the one having the port is the one getting the messages yeah dude i'm
so glad you mentioned that because i just found my first you know bug using message ports in a live
hacking event maybe well i won't say exactly when because because that'll give it away but but within
the past year right um and and it was uh it was very interesting and i think one of the things that that was
crazy there is it it sometimes people will just get a port and then they'll just shove data into it
without doing you know origin checks or anything like that too no no no so you know it actually even
creates more complexity and more room for vulnerabilities when you when you're utilizing
the message port stuff yeah and it's fun because you can you can have a message port from one little
iframe and if you get hold of that message port you can take it into a different iframe and then the
the the the window thinking it sends sends it to the iframe it's actually sending it cross domain
somewhere else so yeah that message port can be you can juggle that message port wherever you want
which is quite kind of funny that it's like just a connection it's basically like a a socket that you
can that shuffles data it's i'm also kind of surprised that we haven't seen more post message based
tooling out there like maybe i'm just naive but your post message tracker is pretty much the only
extension that i've seen that that does anything like this so um one thanks for doing that because
otherwise you would have no introspection i use it i use it every day myself it's my the only probably
extension i use myself and every every day i'm looking at it so it's like i'm it's a good example
of like writing something that would you would use yourself yeah and it's 100 like that like it doesn't
go a day without me looking at it i i'd kind of like also to just to highlight you know
the importance of understanding browser mechanics and stuff like that so let's say for example you
you you know post message stuff was just coming out or something like that right and you go to a page
and you see a a an iframe open up or not an iframe a pop-up you know open up and it does something and
then it you know that change somehow seems to appear back on the on the original window right yeah and you
don't see any http requests so it's not pushing it out to the server and not coming back right so
you're like wait a second how the heck is this working because if you have a an understanding of
browser mechanics you you know you would need you need some sort of reference to pass it and that
sort of thing yeah same origin kind of works still yeah same origin is fine for that yeah yeah so it's
important to understand you know if it's happening cross origin like that you can't just you know say parent
you know or opener dot you know window you know whatever and just define variables or trigger
callbacks in the parent window if it's cross-origin so you so having a strong understanding of same
origin policy having a strong um understanding of of um window references you know yeah those sort of
things are essential to be able to identify these sort of issues um yeah for sure as the technology evolves
absolutely so and i think i one one thing that i i did some talks on it but i think is
there will be a lot more bugs on it it's it's client-side race conditions with post message i i think
that's i think i was early on with it uh but i think that there are much more places to investigate
that might be similarly vulnerable to it i i i don't have so i've got a couple client-side race conditions
um in place um bugs that i've found and i'm actually doing some research on them right now uh
which i'll share with you after this after this chat um and maybe we can collab on it because uh
the implications of it are pretty gnarly um but uh it's i need to do what you did with uh a lot 30
dancing and just like you know work through all the all the pathways yeah work with all the pathways to it
but yeah i mean there's so many things that can be said about that one piece that is not super relevant
to the to the um to the bug that the or to the research that i'm talking about is the the concept
of client-side race conditions via post message when um one of the people is using json.parse so
the thing about json.parse is that it it when you're parsing that that json data from a string back
into a json object that takes computational power to load up all those objects right so i had a
scenario when i was getting a post message at two different windows at the same time right and i
needed to be so this window was relay the first window that would receive the post message was
relaying it to me the attacker but then that first window would respond to the post message and set some
configuration settings right so i had to receive it needed the message to be first but you also needed
to read it faster than the other exactly so the first the first window that received it was using
json.parse yeah and instead matching i guess exactly i used i used just substring right to extract
this this variable that i needed to send the message and was able to win the race back to the first window
and and so uh that's it that's a cool little little tip i love those those things are are beautiful
json.parse is a little bit um computationally also also i think like the whole concept of
sending uh object like arbitrary objects i know file descriptor made one of those using blob yeah
but there there are a bunch like you can send a regex object yeah and and so there's a bunch of
these like if this is not a string kind of bugs that you can find just because you're sending
a completely different object with post message uh i think it's like file blob regex there's a bunch of
more that you can uh you can send over wow i didn't know that actually i got to look into that and i
know that some some providers have implemented frameworks where like serialization and deserialization
frameworks that just make my life terrible they are crazy i know i know exactly what you mean i've
seen those as well yeah it takes a lot a lot of time but sometimes in those cases i i rather look for
the the syncs first exactly or like like is it even you know it's time to go down this path yeah
exactly yeah no totally those are tricky i agree wow um all right moving along i'm gonna i'm gonna hit
this next one pretty quickly but i will say for any of you that are are aspiring to be live hacking event
participants uh this talk by by franz uh live hacking like an mvh a walkthrough on methodology
and strategies to win big uh is an amazing talk that talks about the life hacking event experience
and how to do well at live hacking events um so we talk about a lot of this stuff as well also let me
just say uh as of this past vegas i have been uh what is it d seeded unseeded as the as tied for the
most mvhs and now franz has taken back his rightful title as um you know mvh master of sorts so
i will get that back franz give me some time at some point at some point i guess uh but this this
you know this talk goes through essentially uh the live hacking event flow and and actually some of the
og live hacking event flow where you would like you know have to use bounty please which is a a uh
yeah the tool that franz wrote yeah to automatically submit all your bugs in the beginning what a
crazy time man where you would just not where you would like get if you didn't get your bug in fast
enough it was just there was no bounty like what the heck no exactly i think i think it was also you
got duped because if someone posted it before you didn't have a dupe window basically yeah it's crazy so
yeah it was it was kind of weird it like incentivized building those toolings uh for sure but i know
people i i think there have been live hacking events lately also needed it like that needed to get in
things quick so i've gotten requests to like like reignite that project man because like and and i think
it's also to be honest because a lot of people tend to write markdown reports themselves first and then
trying to like get it in squeeze it into the the bounty platform so um for those of you that my
favorite part about bounty please by the way is that it's all written in bash yeah okay yeah i love
that damn i write everything in bash yeah so i was gonna ask that same question joel like dude why do
you write everything in bash like like pipelines man you can it's like a functional functional language
because you can pipe everything through everything like it's it's like that's where python
python python python script into some other python i mean sure but but now you like your whole script
is based on piping data through you know conversions and and things so i think i think it's just uh my
mentality is not like this is a script and this is a pipeline with the script it's more like my script
is my pipeline or often i think it's like an organic thing of like my my my script is becoming it's becoming
a script because i used a pipeline and now i'm like so i think it's just my mentality of like that's and
i think i i tend to use it so much also because it's like it goes so fast on building it yeah uh you
know we'll we'll roll away we'll let you we'll let that fly we'll let that slide no worries um and and
we'll i wanted to talk to you about collaboration in live hacking events and i want to read a quote from
um um the the this article and you give a lot of great advice uh in this article or in this um in
this slide deck about um essentially doing the work that other people aren't willing to do uh um
focusing on the boring stuff and and you know configuring all the things that other hackers won't
configure that's the way to get the big bounties and the way to hit sort of untapped attack surface
and that's great so i wanted to shout that out but i also wanted to talk about this section where
you said uh when you're talking about teaming because teaming is something that we talk about
on critical thinking a lot joel and i joel is one of the the few people um actually one of the only
people i think that i have ever done in my opinion successfully done a a collaboration with over the
past five years where it was a full from the beginning to the end collaboration right yeah um yeah
and i think that's because i've been burned a little bit in the past on large teams um and and that
that is what it is everyone needs to have that learning experience but i get a little bit of a
bad rap for being anti-collaboration now i'm not anti-collaboration by any stretch um but you give
some really great advice here so let me read that with regards to teaming team up with someone that one
will put similar effort into as you two might know stuff you don't three helps you cover more attack
surface four you can communicate with and brain stream or brain stream uh brainstorm and then you
say both yeah right exactly uh if you look at uh freaking matthias's dms it might be seem more of a
brain stream than a brainstorm i mean it makes sense brainstorm also um and then you say keep keep teams
small two to four if three or more effort will differ allow splitting differently for two people 50 is
always the simplest so that was sort of like the brain dump of of collaboration wisdom you did back
in the day do you still hold to all that absolutely 100 i think and i i think it's very interesting also
in terms of like where uh when like i do try to collaborate with new people all the time um and and
you know once or twice sometimes maybe around one bug and sometimes maybe you know during an event or
during just a target uh sometimes even and i always come to the conclusion that it's like a lot easier
to do it two people uh because then it's it's much easier to you know it's very simple then if if both
are collaborating then then the full team is there but if you're three maybe two of them are working
together one night the other one can't and like it's it it just after two it becomes like really hard to
align that everybody's doing equal work because you do you don't want to end up in like me personally
would not like to end up in the in the scenario where i get paid for doing nothing and i hope that
other people don't feel great about that either it's like because i wouldn't i i i sometimes feel bad
with one person when that person is providing much more than i do uh but i i at least try to put in the
time trying to find things uh but so i i struggle a lot with uh you know often with like i'm like i
don't need to be collaborator on this thing because i didn't do anything that kind of mentality uh myself
so i really like i enjoy people having the same kind of mentality themselves uh and you quite quickly
notice the ones that don't really care and like almost gets to you know ride on a sandwich it's a
swedish proverb but but like uh gets gets to do things are getting paid for not doing it kind of
proverb is that ride on a sandwich it's actually it's actually ride on the shrimp sandwich
what the frick yeah yeah it's like yeah yeah it's weird but yeah so it's i i and and so that's why
like when you identify the people that like kind of align with you on those things it becomes so much
easier to like collaborate and like just focus on the fun stuff which is the hacking part and and try
to you know find the best way uh to escalate the bug yeah i mean that's one of the things i really love
about live hacking events is that i find that more often than not any random person at a live hacking
event that i walk up to i'm able to almost like jump the line and get to a communication level that
like it's very hard to establish with other people just out of out of the gate and part of that i think
is just that like we all have a similar kind of technical background we all have a very common base of
knowledge about like web security or just even just security in general and like the types of bugs and
stuff and if you can get past that and just start talking immediately about like technical problems
and being on the same page that helps so much with actually making progress with bugs i see this all
the time when me and justin uh co-hack essentially where we'll sit down at a live hacking event and
maybe one of us will drive and the other one is just really just like sitting there like looking
like seeing and like the communication like we don't even speak in sentences it's just like yeah
yeah exactly like oh that's really yeah i mean have we tried doing x y like and we don't even like
we kind of just like we're looking at the same thing we're consuming the same thing we can kind
of jump through communication and almost in shortcuts um and i really love being able to do that when you
get to like more and more people that starts to fall apart and it becomes less scalable i think
probably the most you can do that with is maybe like four people where you have four people like
sort of huddled around like throwing ideas before you start to run into communication problems not not even
just like the the like barrier to to communication but just like too many people are talking at the
same time or like there's too many ideas running around there's or there's too many perspectives
where it's like we're not you know like we're never really going down a full path because somebody you
know if three people think one thing and the other person's like wow but like you know what about this
thing and then you get sidetracked so it definitely does work best with with two i think
yeah for sure and i i the one the the times we've been four it has naturally become you know pairs uh
so you have two and two that is like very much yeah and we've had done we have done some live hacking
events for people but sometimes in those like you sometimes also like you need to be prepared to have
like very tough discussions like if it goes well you need to have tough discussions on like hey guys me
and you know x put in a little bit more time than you guys i are you all like fine with us you know
getting a larger percentage of whatever it is and and and those kind of discussions and if you can't
have those or if they turn you know ugly then it's going to be a really hard time to to collaborate in
the future but if you can have those great ones then it doesn't you know the reason the reason i bring
this topic up often on the podcast is because i want people to be aware of the fact that there
there are some sticky situations you can get into with this right absolutely so anyone going into
collaboration needs to know that there's risk and there's reward um and and you need to be ready to
have these these conversations and here's the other thing a lot of people will take the high road and
say like you know it's it's it's just money you know it's not a big deal but i've found that those
people will harbor resentment and they'll they'll leave that that that resentment in their heart right and
that that's not that's not sometimes without knowing exactly sometimes without knowing and
that that's not helpful for the community you know and and so no i think i i think it's absolutely
important to like if you can feel that you dare to have that discussions with the people you collaborate
with that's a really good situation to be in but because if you feel that you can't take that up
uh then maybe you should i don't know then it then it becomes like if you if you feel that like i will
put that back even personally like i will avoid not saying anything even though i feel bad like as
you said like you would feel bad going forward like it's much better to like ease it up and say like
hey guys like i i put in a lot of time in this and so did he or something can we do something about it and let them you know see where they are what they are suggesting or you know
maybe they are saying yeah we 100 agree then okay then you have then you you can align that and then everybody's happy
um these problems you don't really have these problems when uh when you don't find bugs though
that's true like these are these are like the happy problems yeah it's good problems to have and it's really good to train yourself to have those discussions
because you might get stepped on if not and that's not a great feeling to have either so um so i know some people are like trying to measure how much work they put in compared to each other and stuff but i don't i don't think that's uh that's uh a good way either it's just gonna get dirty uh but but i i think it's it's all around finding the people that you know are putting in the time that you and you need to try right you need to try with with people and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and
and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and and